اليد الميته وقرار نووي التهديد النووي
الذي لوح به الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
عده مرات يعود الى الواجهه بعد تصريحات
حول ابرام بلاده اتفاقا مع جارتها روسيا
البيضاء لنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه على
اراضيها لكن من يملك قرارا نووي في روسيا
وماذا تعني اليد الميته العقيده الروسيه
النوويه تؤكد ان الرئيس بوتين يعتبر صانع
القرار النهائي عندما يتعلق الامر
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه الروسيه سواء
الاستراتيجيه ام غير الاستراتيجيه وتاكيد
لهذا فقد شاهدنا بوتين مرارا يحمل معه ما
تسمى الحقيبه النوويه اينما ذهب وفي كل
الاوقات
وبما ان الزعيم الكرملين صاحب القرار في
اطلاق الصواريخ النوويه فانه يعتمد على
نظام خاص لتنشيط هذا السلاح ويعرف في
روسيا باليد الميته اوداد هاند التي تعني
نظام تحكم الي باجهزه حاسوب تقرر ما يسمى
يوم القيامه والذي سيطلق تلقائيا الصواريخ
الباليستيه النوويه الروسيه العابره
للقارات لكن السؤال الاهم متى سيفعل هذا
النظام نظام اليد الميته يفعل في حال
تاكدت روسيا من انها تواجه هجوما نوويا
استراتيجيا وسيكون فقط بضغطه زر من الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين فيما يوجد نظام مماثل في
الولايات المتحده يعرف باسم نظام اتصالات
الصواريخ في حالات الطوارئ